celebrate your wins so I'm filming this
video on video day from the studio
instead of using my iPad and walking
because yesterday I didn't go to Whole
Foods to write the book is the book
series because it was my anniversary
with my wife and she actually didn't
want to celebrate anything he's like
well let's just go for dinner or
something they're like no we've gotta
you gotta celebrate because I think it's
easy to lose track of the things that
bring you joy and easy to move on to
like the next thing the next stage and
in business and in life I believe it's
important to celebrate the things that
make you happy that is a win right
another year together we're happy we're
healthy we should celebrate that and so
I had the day basically planning what we
were going to do I didn't have the time
to go write the book but I think it's
important and so I think entrepreneurs
tend to not celebrate enough obviously
in the personal lives remembering
anniversaries and birthdays but in
business you know if you hit a goal
celebrated its a good chance for you to
feel good for a few minutes before
moving on to the next goal and also if
you have a team for them to feel
encouraged and energized and feel
recognized and that they're doing
something important because all you're
doing is putting your foot on the gas
you don't think time to reflect and
celebrate then you could burn out so
celebrate your wins to the questions
Chris would you start doing videos about
your book if you're almost done I don't
think it's ever too late to start to
make videos about your book you know I
think if anything I'm doing it early
right I'm doing it from the beginning
from when I started writing I started
making these videos for you guys it's
built this traction in history you can
watch each episode and see how far along
I've come but if I was just starting now
if I'm close to finishing my book which
I am I would have no problems in doing
it right now I still have another year
plus before the book even comes out so
there's time in there to start the book
or I start doing the video when the book
is released right it's never too late to
start just like it's never too late to
start your business just start it right
your books almost done great start today
make a video make another video
the video build momentum mark bhangra
even brings the passion love it mark I
know you're a longtime subscriber a
close friend I have no idea what that
means you guys know leave a comment
simply soccer also quick question you
mentioned to not motivate or change
other people because it is difficult to
change people and to instead find people
who are already determined and motivated
my question is where do you find these
people most who I come across are just
going through the motions this includes
my friends and family I would agree i
think most people in life are just going
through the motions and the decision you
have to make is do you want to work with
average ordinary people who don't care
about doing something bigger that's
align with your vision or work with
people who help make you come alive and
love what the company is all about I
think how I found people most of the
people that I found haven't been from
personal connections haven't been from
one-on-one recommendations it's been by
posting jobs and having a really clear
description of what I'm looking for and
it starts with you staining for
something right like are you clear
enough in what you're doing so that
people are attracted to you and want to
come and work for you and want to tell
their friends about you right is that
really clear up front are you leading
with that because a lot of times you
look at a typical job ad you look at how
people explain what they do they talk
exactly about what they do right oh I'm
a carpenter or I'm a dance instructor
right or do you lead with your vision do
you lead with I'm trying to change the
lives of a billion entrepreneurs right
how you communicate and express what
your business is all about is important
because you might be locked into the
current thinking of how everybody else
promotes themselves and just talking
about what you do and how you do it
missing the big vision and so you don't
give people anything to tack on to you
know I'm about believe I ooze believe
it's on the shirt right it's on the wall
it's in every message that I come out
with and so it's easier for me to
attract people who love my message
because it's so front and center if you
don't love believe you're going to hate
you wouldn't even apply like you're
going to hate working on my team but if
you love believe when you love helping
entrepreneurs it's one of the best
places in the world to work at and
are you that clear in your messaging and
if you're not then you should start
getting there skunk fu 25 I love that
name is name is insane I feel like it's
a troll named like you're you fu you
skunk but there's always good questions
is there a way to get a signed book
probably uh you know I like to do a lot
of stuff with my community and my fans
I'm making these videos for you guys I'm
answering comments and so I'd expect
that we're going to be doing some events
we might be going in different cities or
be able to order copies online again my
mind is not twigged yet to the promotion
side of the book and the tour that we
might have because it's so far away from
where we are right now but I appreciate
that comment I'm going to file it away
you know lock it in here and when that
time comes I have noted that it's an
important thing and we'll make sure that
happens for you Daniel Hernandez what
about motivational coaches should they
stop trying to motivate people what
should these coaches do instead so that
was back to my video last week about
encouraging people to think bigger and I
want entrepreneurs to think bigger and I
want them to bring on team members who
like their big vision you know if you're
a motivational coach then your business
is trying to help people believe in
themselves and I like that like I think
in some ways I'm a motivational coach
right you may not have people in your
life who believe in you and who wants
you to be great and love your big ideas
and I know a lot of people don't have
friends and family who do support them
and believe in them and they watch my
videos as a way to get that inspiration
motivation so I get that and that's a
service that you're doing great what I'm
talking about is building a team I don't
want to have to build a team where I
have to motivate my partner every day or
I have to motivate people who work for
me every day and remind them every
single day about what they're doing
right I want people to be on my team who
love what we're all about and also have
ideas of their own for how we can make
something even bigger that's not to say
that everybody doesn't need a little bit
of motivation every now and then I need
it to write like you guys are motivation
for me looking at the comments and the
feedback motivates me to want to do
something bigger so we all need it
nobody's perfect but if you have to give
that to somebody
every single day and they walk in and
they're down and you have to build them
up that's draining for you right so it's
better for you to find somebody who's a
better fit and better for them to go do
something that they are more excited and
passionate about so if I'm a
motivational coach I think it's a little
bit of a different angle where I'm being
paid to help these clients out and as I
bring on people on my team I want people
who love motivating others as well right
again you don't want to have to motivate
your staff to do work you want them to
be self motivated by the mission that
you're on chris lewis it became
political i don't know what that means
either getting the random comments today
or maybe I'm just not on my game and
don't understand what's happening I
would love clarification leave a comment
below inga I will get your book for sure
thank you I appreciate that i hope i
pronounced your name properly this time
bingo i think last time I said Inge so
Inga I appreciate it let me know if I
got it right Sam so you're writing the
book is there any audio CD available
because I prefer listening and reading I
like listening over and over again in my
car when driving thank you for that yes
and I recommend not reading and driving
at the same time again it's something
that I haven't thought too far about I'm
assuming there will be some kind of
audio version I appreciate you put it on
my radar right now it's in the book
writing and finishing an execution phase
once I've given it off to the publisher
which should be in January then I can
focus on whatever we need to do to get
it ready to be printed and then the
promotion and marketing side of it so I
appreciate that feedback you guys want
an audio version I will make sure that
we discuss it and see how to make it
happen last question Zeno I don't know
about buying a thousand copies but
although i'm not an entrepreneur i'm
looking forward to the book sucks that
it takes a year after its in for it to
be released I appreciate that support
and you don't have to buy a thousand
copies to support me you know buying one
is great find some of your friends and
family I also appreciate it in terms of
what was it again Oh taking a year in
terms of taking a year yeah I don't get
it either it's frustrating you know as
entrepreneurs you want things done now
you have a vision of a dream I'm out
executing against it I'm hustling I
don't understand why it takes so long
but in my working with bigger companies
you find that things take a while and I
can't change them I can only
change my reaction to it so doing things
like this making videos updating on the
process feels good to me I'm hustling
while I'm waiting and we will all learn
together what happens in that year
before a book comes out so I'm excited
about the process as well to be able to
educate you guys so thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video I'd love to know what you think of
it leave a comment you have a question
for me about my book the book writing
process the topic that I talked about
today leave it in the comments below and
I will answer it on next week's edition
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon